Speaker 1: A pumpkin. Orange, sweaty and
slurring. Donald Trump is now giving marching
orders to Republicans who have taken control
of the House of Representatives. I don't know
that they're listening to Trump. I don't know
that they care what Trump says anymore. Some
of them anyway. But Donald Trump put out a
video two and a half minutes long telling
Republicans exactly what he expects them to do.
We have not digitally altered this video. This
is really Trump's physical appearance. This
is really Trump's voice. Notice also the jump
cut's done terribly. Trump really struggles
to record this drivel, so they often have to
take it a sentence at a time. Usually when you do
this, you do the jump cut from a different angle,
so it's not obvious that it's stitched together
with with Trump, it's just a disaster. Everything
about this video is a disaster. Let's take a look.
Speaker 2: The new House Committee on the
Weaponization of the federal Government is a
rare chance to expose the breathtaking corruption
of the security state, the
media and the Washington swamp.
Speaker 1: Is Trump okay? I mean, this level
of sweating, I almost wonder whether the orange
fake tan is to cover something else going
on. His eyes are almost completely swollen,
shut like slits. I mean, it does not look good.
Speaker 2: Here are just a few of the questions
the committee hopefully will be asking. Who
in the Mueller team was in charge of leaking?
Speaker 1: Okay, so this was a smart
jump cut. They actually went to the side.
Speaker 2: Grid information and fake news stories
to dishonest journalists, of which are many
to perpetrate the Russia hoax. And that's
what it was. Turned out. It was a total hoax.
It was all misinformation. It was all a horrible
thing that was given to the people of our country
illegally by a fake press and a corrupt press.
Speaker 1: And understand that there was
nothing illegal about the Russia probe.
Speaker 2: Nothing by corrupt politicians. Today,
the fake Steele dossier was first published
because they knew it was fake, and they knew that
some time there'd be a guy like Trump that wants
to go after them. How many fake news journalists
been paid or compensated by U.S. government
agencies directly or indirectly, for their role in
spreading domestic disinformation like the FBI did
with Twitter, who orchestrated the FBI's repeated
operations to interfere in domestic politics?
Speaker 1: I genuinely don't think Trump even
understands the words he's reading
off the prompter. He seems lost in
the prompter and completely disconnected
from the meaning of what he's saying.
Speaker 2: In weeks of
multiple US election seasons.
Speaker 1: Right.
Speaker 2: And specifically, and most importantly,
in the presidential election of 2020, what the
FBI did was suppress anything bad about Biden
and go all out, put it all out there. If there
was anything at all bad about Trump and if
there wasn't anything bad, we'll make it up.
Speaker 1: Now, None of this is true. I know
you know that. And of course,
he doesn't cite any examples.
Speaker 2: That was a rigged election
just by itself. All the federal agents.
Speaker 1: And his that jump cut
was so bad, they cut off one of
Trump's words. Who's editing these things?
Speaker 2: Performance and pressing the
crowd toward the Capitol? On January
six. And who is reps? Tell me about
reps. Where does he come from? I think we know.
Speaker 1: This is Trump feeding this conspiracy
theory that Ray Epps, a man who was videotaped
in D.C. the day before the January six riots,
that the idea that some right wingers have is
that he was actually an FBI either informant
or actual agent. Of course, there is no
evidence of that whatsoever, and there's
just no evidence of that whatsoever, period.
Speaker 2: In addition, the committee needs to
do a full review of Pfizer warrants. Pfizer,
a B, we should also get a full report.
Speaker 1: On there, an audio glitch
that was in the video there. So,
you know, just a disastrous video, a.
Speaker 2: Domestic surveillance of
MAGA supporters that has taken place under
Biden or Obama. And the radical left and
the divider is very, in fact, deep seated.
Speaker 1: It's a deep seated, deep state.
Speaker 2: The greatest threat American
freedom in generations has seen. And their
collusion with the fake news media is
absolutely atrocious. This committee is
a vital chance to bring it all to light.
Speaker 1: And this is arguably the worst
that Trump has sounded. Forget about how he
looks struggling to put together these words.
And of course, he is pretending as though
he is now going to direct these ridiculous
committees that Republicans are putting
together, the weaponisation committee,
their COVID committee, which is not really
a COVID committee. It's sort of like a get
Fauci committee. Trump believes he is now going
to direct Republicans in their investigations,
if that's what you're going to call them. Maybe
he's right. I am not going to assume until we see
is Trump still in control of the Republican Party
or is he not? His endorsement record in contested
races in November was not particularly good, as
you know. And so we'll see what the Republicans
are going to listen to, Trump or not, but he
really doesn't look good. And the rallies,
I guess, are starting soon this weekend. There's
going to be it's called an event. I guess it's
not really a rally. I don't know what it is in
South Carolina. I told you Trump was struggling
to find state legislators willing to go up on
stage and support him. Our correspondent Luke
Beasley is going to be there interviewing people
and hopefully some of the questions Luke asks
will be about. Like, do you still think that that
this is the guy that's good for your party, but
it's just amateur hour in every way, the reading,
the filming, the audio, it's completely bonkers.